so the blue one in the middle of this of
this series is argon so again this is a
very nice glass tube that we've had made
with a low pressure of argon inside we
put a potential across from the two air
ends here and here and this excites all
of the argon molecules inside so you can
see this wonderful characteristic eerie
blue glow coming off from the argon
argon is one of the noble gases or
so-called rare gases it's not really
quite so rare it consists in quite a
high percentage nearly 1 percent of the
atmosphere if I look at the one in the
middle I can see lots and lots of lines
in the blue and the green region and
these are all specific to the individual
atoms that are in the in the tubes
themselves but it's very run reactive so
only chemists found it quite difficult
to identify in fact it was only sir
William Ramsay that identified the argon
in 1894 and he was in fact the first
person in Britain to win the Nobel Prize
for chemistry so if we turn off the
power to this we turn off the M
potential and then we don't excite the
molecules so what we'd see is just a
clear glass tube with no visible sign of
anything inside and only when we turn on
the potential do we excite the molecules
so that they emit and give us these
really quite wonderful colors